How to manage updates for standard deployments of BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition.
Please note in order to perform an update, Enterprise Server needs network access to
portswigger.net. Additionally, updates work differently for Kubernetes deployments.
For more information on updating Kubernetes deployments, please see our documentation
updating BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition on Kubernetes. Now as a first step, we can
configure automatic updates if we navigate to settings and updates. We'll see here that
we have automatic updates enabled for both the Enterprise Server and BIRT scanner.
We can disable one or both. If we would prefer to manually check for updates, we
can select the check for updates button at any time and the system will let us know
which updates are available and we can select the install update button to have
that update installed. If your Enterprise Server does not have network access, you can
also manually update both BIRT scanner and BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition and this
ensures that you benefit from the latest improvements in scan checks. To do so,
navigate to our release page, select Enterprise and the relevant release. Now
from the drop-down you can select updater and this will apply to the Enterprise
server update itself or BIRT scanner if you want to update BIRT scanner. Once the file has
been downloaded, we can navigate back to Enterprise and select upload zip file. Please
note that BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition sends out automated email notifications
whenever a new update is available. In order to receive these updates, you will need to
connect BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition to your email server. For more information on this,
please see our documentation configuring your SMTP server. Also note that there may be some downtime
during updates and the impact of applying an update in terms of downtime is as follows. Updates
to BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition will cause some downtime while the update is applied. The web UI,
REST API and GraphQL API will be unavailable during the update and any scans that are configured to
start during the update will be delayed until it is completed. Scans that are already running at the
time of the update are unaffected. To reduce the impact of downtime, you can restrict automatic
updates of BIRT Suite Enterprise Edition to specific date and times. Updates to BIRT
Scanner do not cause any downtime. Scans that are already running at the time of the update will
continue using the version of BIRT Scanner that they started with. New scans that start after the
update will use the updated version of BIRT Scanner. We do recommend that you enable automatic
updates of BIRT Scanner to make sure that the latest scan checks are available. Over time,
there might be backwards compatibility limitations on either component in relation to the other. If
one component has not been updated for some time, you may have to update it before any further updates
can be made to the other component. As you can see here, the updates page will indicate if this is the
case. Some updates might also require manual intervention. For example, you may have to
accept changes to the software license agreement before an update can be applied. Again, the updates
page will indicate this if that's the case. Thank you.